[Music]
hi I'm Eli Roth for Fandango movie clips
and here are some of my favorite
cannibal films to munch on massacre and
dinosaur Valley
directed by mikael massimo tarantino the
italians master the cannibal genre this
is something that started in 1972 with
Umberto Lenzi van from deep river it
ended in 1985 with Massacre and dinosaur
valley its place like in 1980s movie
that you'd see on cable late at night
with this liked brawler adventure kind
of guy who's having sex with hot girls
and then there's a plane crash
where they land in Dinosaur Valley where
it low and behold there are cannibals
and people get eaten in horrible ways it
is totally cheesy but a really fun film
definitely worth checking out
[Music]
number five mountain of the cannibal god
directed by sergio martino it's one of
those movies that is this jungle
adventure where they try to get up the
mountain and they really shot it in the
jungles of Sri Lanka
it doesn't really play like a cannibal
movie so much as a jungle adventure
movie and that was kind of the feel that
I wanted to have in green inferno it's
definitely a cannibal film but I wanted
to be in that kind of Apocalypse Now
mountain of the cannibal God side it's a
terrific movie Ursula Andress very very
under scene worth checking out number 4
Emanuel in the last cannibals they made
in a manual movie where she goes to
investigate cannibalism and it actually
turns into a pretty damn good cannibal
movie it also has like amazing sex
scenes in it so you're like oh look
they're hot they go bathing in the river
you get this like fantastic lesbian
scene it's like you're watching an
awesome skinemax movie and then the
scene of them arriving at the village
you're like wow this is this is really
good like they really go for it and
they're tying them up and splitting them
open and eating them it's a pretty damn
awesome if you want hard you've got to
watch last cannibal world Ultima mondo
Conti Bali directed by Raja rodeado
the guy is trying to find the last tribe
and he goes and he's kept in a pit and
the kids were pissing on him and stuff
he witnesses the savage rituals and that
was kind of the thrill of these movies
is that you're going to another time and
seeing like what shocking things did
they do what was this primitive man do
there's a lot of fantastic scenes
there's a little nod with a little
finger trick that we do in Gran faretta
to last cannibal worlds but we will get
back to de o'donnell later of number 2
umberto lenzi cannibal ferox also known
as make them die slowly this is great he
makes this movie called cannibal ferox
comes out in italy he doesn't know this
but a producer took the movie and just
released it and called it make them die
slowly so he didn't even know his movie
was being released on Broadway it was a
huge hit and that's just one of those
titles where you know had this giant
video box and you were just waiting to
see them get it lots of animal killing
you got to get over that just no animals
are gonna get killed the director claims
that they ate the animals after they
killed them I understand it I do stuff
with PETA it's hard to watch it's 1980
things were different Cannibal Holocaust
is the number one cannibal film of all
time the genius of it created the film
within a film the same formula Blair
which used he actually got the actors to
agree to dis
here for a year after he made the movie
so people really thought they died and
they did it they signed contract and
they disappeared now this is obviously
1979 1980 is before the internet so it's
hard to track people down people were so
shocked by this movie Dada Dada was
brought up on murder charges and
obscenity charges and he had to go to
court in Rome is a famous scene where
girls impaled on a pole his makeup
artist had to bring her in and he had to
fly the actors from New York and say no
I didn't actually kill the people that's
how cool that movie is massacre in
dinosaur Valley Mountain of the cannibal
god Emmanuel in the last cannibals
Ultima mundo canibal a cannibal ferox
Cannibal Holocaust I'm Eli Roth for
Fandango movie clips those films are a
cannibal rite of passage if you can
survive them then you are definitely
ready for the green inferno in theaters
everywhere September 25th and you take
the heat